okay so what we're doing today uh we're
developing a an application a web
application
uh that
that serves the funniest uh tech tweets
that can be found
and we want the entire works we want
schema validation we want api
documentation
we want it to run fast and we want
to develop fast so that's why we chose
first api a framework created by
sebastian ramirez not too long ago i
think a year and a half
so without further ado
let's get started
first i'm initializing
i'm initializing the app instance
okay
and as we can see now we initialize the
first api um everything is live coding
here
the only thing that is prepared in
advance is the tweets database
and
some files with with comments
uh that will guide it through so right
now
i'm going to write something that will
display this those comments during the
session i'm going to use a feature
called
uh event handler
for
and i'm going to use the startup event
so let's see how it goes i'm annotating
the app and i'm saying
on event and the event that i'm
providing it is the startup event
okay
and right now i'm going to open a
comments file
sorry about that
okay and i'm using uh
i'm using calcite to display
the format the json a bit
i think you fancy here
okay
um
so now we're going to run the app
fast api is a web framework and it uses
an ascii web server called uvicon so
right now
we're going to run it
we also use
reload flag
which reloads the app while we're making
changes
which is great for development but make
sure it doesn't go into production
okay
so without further ado let's implement
our first http handler
we'll start with
the http method get and we're going to
display all the tech tweets
that we have
okay and now in opening
my database which is a json file
i'm not saying that
this should be a production database but
it's
not saying it's not but it's not the
problem that we're trying to trying to
solve at the moment
okay
so the app got reloaded
and
okay so we have a first web application
and
how can we consume it
i like to consume it with a command line
application called crl
it's everywhere
and it has all the features that you
want that you want and you're in your id
scope so that's great
okay and we can see that we're getting a
response back which is great this is
exactly what we're hoping for
i like to combine it with an additional
command line application called jq and
it pretty fast json output so it's much
more pleasant from the eye
um okay
you didn't see the comment properly
because i had uh
i had a title here we can see it better
right now
and another great thing about first api
is that it takes all the handlers all
the http handlers that you are writing
and auto creates a documentation out of
it so i'll show you how it looks like
it's
okay it doesn't let me show it to you
that's a shame
yep
i don't know what to do
okay never mind i'll show it and i'll
show it in the chat later
but it gives documentation trust my word
for it
um
moving on
we're going to do a crowd here
and
basically i'm going to take the i o that
is here and i'm going to move it
uh to another model uh we did it at the
first attempt with firefox so right now
i'm just
going to call it
we fix the import
you can see they are get reloaded
and we can see that it's still working
and what i did here with the i o it's a
similar pattern the first api is an
amazing project generation template
and in that project generation template
you can see everything development
deployment front and back end
tests everything and
so the way i like to explore new
technologies is either take this
template that is ready as possible
and and use it and then do minor changes
to to put my business knowledge here or
i can
start from scratch and only put in the
stuff that i want this is the the
pattern that we are going to use now
okay so this was about prod
moving on to our next example
okay um you can use fast api is both
synchronous and asynchronous you can
also use them together
meaning that here we obstructed the i o
but this
if this io is not blocking i o we can
make the http under x inc
and our application can work can still
work and we can also do mix and match
moving on
moving on is we're going to talk about
about query params
and
first api has an interesting approach
here
it uses a dependency injection pattern
meaning that those
parameters are not available during
development time but at one time they
magically appear
so let's start with query params as our
tech tweets
database gets larger this code gets
slower and we want to limit
and what's being returned here if we
have a ui we might also want to page it
so there are many use case for it
so i'm saying that
it has a choreogram named size
and it's type is an integer
and
right now i'm going to slice the array
that is being returned
the app is being reloaded and let's see
that it's working i'm adding a clear
front name size and you can see
we have less stuff coming back
and
moving on
of your recurrence
so
let's implement an event center that is
very similar to the previous one
but with a url program let's say that
every tech tweet that we have is
uniquely identified
by its array index so we'll call it a
tech tweet id
way to define it is very similar to f
strings just without the f
and
i'm injecting the tech boot id
as a dependency
right now
i'm saying that our crowd we can't get
at
the
id index let's see if we implemented it
we implemented it
so the app gets reloaded
and
instead of giving it a creeper i'm
giving the url param
and
you can see we have a unique tech id
tech tweet that is being returned
for certain index
moving on
okay
and when we're talking about uh rest
restful applications usually
forget http method to get data and for
post http those are the
requests that are important and we want
to create
new data we usually do a post request so
let's see how it goes and for possible
quest you provide the data as
as an http body and not as a url program
or a query form
so let's
do a course request
for
tech tweets
click create week you want to add
something
okay
and what
what we dependency inject here
is a pedantic class which
gives us the ability to define strictly
the input schema so
it sounds very complicated but it's
actually pretty simple so let's have a
look we're saying it's getting a tweet
and the tweet is of type tweet
let's create this class tweet and it
it's supposed to inherit from
by daunting base mode
very small
okay
importing it and we're only saying that
it has
one key called content and the content
is a string
and so what we're doing at the moment
[Music]
okay
we are saying okay let's
the crowd to save this tweet
and
save this with content
and what we're going to do that is
customs for
um for post request that creating data
we're going to return
to 101 status code
we can also say that instead of
returning the status code here
we can say that
the user status code here is 201 it's
the same so right now we're going to the
crowd and we're going to
implement the save method
so what we're going to do now we're
going to
we're going to append
it to our database and we're going to
save it so
it will be persisted
between
reloads
open the file for writing
and instead of loading
just get the object and then it gets
[ __ ]
okay
so the update reloaded right now um
okay
so
this is for crl we're saying that
this is a json
that we're sending
data as json and we're sending it to
tech tweets and the data that we send
it's content of a new tweet
okay
and we can see that it got 201 created
so let's see if it's saved
i think it's number four
yeah
okay and we implemented
a post request with a body
so let's say
that you don't know you don't want the
ski you don't know the schema in advance
or you want to do some exploration
and so instead of defining the type you
can
you can say that
it gets addict
and then you can send whatever you want
to json and it's not strict and it's not
validated
but
can allow you to do some exploration
and let's try again i'll try again to
share with you how it looks like on
on the on the schema it didn't let me to
do it earlier
if it will behave right now
yeah okay everything is here so we can
see all
all the http methods that we implemented
it has auto-generated documentation you
can see here the tech tweet id is a url
for arm we can see it is an integer and
we can see that it is required we can
try it out
provide it with the number
we get the response here the status code
and we can also get
the crl command and for the post if we
use a strict schema we can also see the
scheme
okay so let's get back
okay moving on to our next example
okay
qrl is really great it's combined
combining with j combining it with jq is
even greater
but i like to use a python command
application called httpi
which gives in my opinion a much nicer
command line interface
so as you can see
we don't need to use jq and it returns a
colored output and it returns the
headers in different colors
and i prefer to use applications like
command line application like crl
and http
instead of using uh
instead of using like external
applications like postman
because everything is in my id view
i don't need i don't need to go out i'm
inside the development school
and
this is this is my preference i hope you
like it as well
okay
uh right now we're going to talk about
testing okay let's say that okay we have
an application we already see that in i
don't know 15 or 20 minutes we already
implemented three
http handlers if you develop this
application for months you can have uh
hundreds of thousands
of http handlers and they might be
simple they might be complicated but
every time you make a change before we
deliver it to the customers you want to
make sure that everything is working so
you're going to look for an application
and you're trying each route hopefully
and
[Music]
so why not incorporate everything in the
test suit
this will be much more maintainable okay
so um the recommended way to
to test fast api applications is with pi
test
so
it provides a test client
the test client get the test line gets
the application as input
and
you write a function that starts with
tests underscore and it will be picked
up by pi test
and then i can do
and then i can say
response is
client
get by the way the syntax here is
request
syntax so if you know requests you know
how to use
the test clients
okay and let's assert something
the status code is 200
okay
and i run it through pycharm it can be
run to command line as well that i
prefer to do by charm
and we can see here that that the test
packs cool
um
so http
http has a lot of status codes rest api
has a lot of status codes and sometimes
you know you have to use a bunch of them
and you go to other projects and you get
back and you have new team members that
are not necessarily familiar with web
application
so do yourself and everyone a favor and
just be explicit instead of saying
200 or
something else like we had 201 earlier
say
use a built-in enum called http status
and say
ok
it's much more explicit uh if you have a
large test here you can understand
what is supposed to happen in in the
entire flow
uh so be explicit about it and
it will be easier to maintain your
application like this
so using a test line like this is nice
and everything but
it has some limitation
uh it doesn't allow you
to override dependencies and
it doesn't let you to it it doesn't give
you it doesn't uh perform the startup
and shutdown event so a much more
let's call this robust way of using the
the test line is with the fixture
with the bypass fixture
okay we'll call it client
and what it does with the context
manager
we yield the client
and now we pass it that's input here
okay
let's see that everything still passes
yeah and this way let's say
we add authentication
and we don't want authentication for
test but you know it won't pass so we
can do stuff
like override the let's say get current
user and set it as me
and this way we don't need a
authentication for application this is
uh uses that only
that can that can only be executed in
test if you're using uh
it has a fixture and with a contact
solution
so let's say that everything still
passes
okay cool
um
another feature that that i like to use
uh i use it in pycharm it's called
toggle autotest but it's also
there are several tools in
um
with pi test that allows you to to do
this i think python
xdisk or test mode or something like
this or even both
and so basically what it means that if
you have something that that fails
let's face something on
what purpose tested we tested the query
okay so let's say instead i have a bug
here and i'm
raising an http exception
once again i'm explicit the status code
is
it's i don't know internal server l
so
you see the test got auto rerun i didn't
have to do anything and it failed and
i'm getting an explicit failure message
saying
it expected to get an okay 200 but it
got it got an internal server 500
so right now
i'm fixing the bug
and again i'm not doing anything and i
hope
okay
okay and the test got reran
and
it turned successfully so that's a great
pattern i'll recommend you all using
and one last thing that i like to talk
about is that um
when when you develop a fast api
application and gets bigger then your
schema also gets much more complicated
and the input for for the open ai
specification three which is the ui that
i showed you earlier of the api
documentation
and my break so what i like to do i like
to add a test
at the
documentation is generated so right now
i'm
only delivering
an application that i know
this documentation is working as well
no right the oil is wrong
okay
um so that's it
i hope you enjoyed this talk and i hope
you will develop a web application using
first api
and thank you very much
anyone has any questions
[Applause]